[Musik]
Training beim Tabellenführer war die
deckler in Kairo
[Musik]
Frauenfußball in Ägypten ja richtig das
gibt es hier seit etwas mehr als 20
Jahre
ich habe alles mögliche gespielt aber
das ist echt der einzige Sport wo ich
mich wieder finde
um in Ägypten als Frau Fußball zu
spielen sagen sie brauchst du noch mehr
Hingabe und Disziplin als woanders
ich spielte auf der Straße ich komme aus
einem ärmerenviertel ich bete mit Jungs
ich wusste nicht mal dass es
Frauenfußball gibt
gerade junge Frauen stellen alte
Rollenbilder in Frage ihre Stimmen sind
lauter als zuvor
einige Männer wären sich dagegen dass
sie das Problem sind sie verneinen dass
die Gesellschaft männlich ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir wollen dass man an uns glaubt uns
Frauen ermutigt statt uns einzuschränken
Frauen sollten einen größeren Platz in
der Gesellschaft haben hallo
[Musik]
18 Nationalspielerin dazu Nachwuchs in
der U21 und Mittelfeldspielerin bei
ready deckler
dein Shirt ist voller Flecken Mama
wäscht nicht oder was
erstes Training nach den Schule und
uni-prüfungen wiegen und messen nach der
Trainingspause zwei Spiele stehen an der
Nordafrika Cup und dann wenn es läuft
die afrikanische Champions League
ich bin aufgeregt weil diese zwei Spiele
schon auf einem anderen Niveau sind die
Medien werden da sein Talentscouts
werden da sein für mich eine neue
Herausforderung
immer mehr Frauen wollen Fußball lernen
in den sportakademien von Kairo
berichten die Trainer und zum ersten Mal
kämpfen vier starke Clubs um den Titel
die Gesellschaft hier akzeptierte diesen
Sport nicht es war schwer überhaupt eine
Spielerin zu finden jetzt nicht mehr
jetzt gibt es Eltern die erreichen
wollen dass ihre Töchter Fußball spielen
die Welt hat sich geändert die Kultur
hat sich geändert die Gesellschaft
akzeptiert das
trotzdem für Maja war der Staat nicht
einfach
bis ich 15 wurde spielte ich in keinem
Club ich flehte meine Mutter an aber sie
sagte nein also war ich an Akademien
oder spielte im Schulclub mit Jungen
zusammen
langsam verändert sich der Blick auf sie
nicht nur beim Fußball Frauen können
mehr als nur Ehefrau Köchin Mutter aber
wie weit dürften sie sich entwickeln
eine Millionenstadt im Nil Delta wenn es
eine Hauptstadt für Hockey gebe in
Ägypten dann wäre sie hier
hatte zum ersten Mal mit vier Jahren
einen Hockeyschläger in der Hand jetzt
spielt sie für die Frauenmannschaft
Scharia Tabellenführer und Sieger beim
Afrika-Cup
nein Diät okay ist
98,5% meines Lebens das womit ich am
meisten Zeit verbringe was ich am
liebsten mache nichts kann mich mehr aus
dem Stress herausziehen als das Stadion
und Hockey
an Spielerinnen mangele es Ihnen hier
nicht sagen sie aber es fehlen starke
Gegner sie vermissen Spiele im Ausland
obwohl es ein Halbfinale ist ist das
ägyptische Fernsehen nicht gekommen wie
diesen Sport bekannt machen wenn niemand
etwas davon mitbekommt
ehrlich gesagt werden Sportlerinnen hier
diskriminiert gerade beim Hockey unsere
Frauen werden nicht fair behandelt wir
sind afrikanische Meister aber durften
nicht erneut teilnehmen weil angeblich
kein Geld da ist für uns während die
Männer hinreisen durften
ohne die Mütter ginge nichts oft sind
sie die Hauptsponsoren manche kaufen
heimlich Ausrüstung ohne dass die Väter
es mitbekommen
er will nicht dass unsere Tochter reist
ich versuche dann ihn zu überzeugen und
mache Druck am Ende gewinne ich und sie
darf reisen weil ich mag das Spiel
maria hat wieder einmal gewonnen
manche im Team erhielten Angebote in
Europa zu spielen aber Studium und
Kinder hielten sie davon ab würde Maja
safirdin ein solches Angebot annehmen
ich glaube nicht dass mein Vater das
absolut ablehnen würde meine Eltern sind
flexibel denke ich vielleicht müsste
mein Bruder mit reisen weil Sie sicher
sein wollen dass ich dort geschützt bin
treiben alle Kinder Sport
manchmal in gemischten Teams im
Karateverein des Sohnes aber eine Frau
gerade den schwarzen Gürtel gemacht
alles sei möglich so lange Frauen dabei
ihre Keuschheit nicht verlieren
wir sagen bei uns ein Mädchen ist wie
ein Diamant solange dieser Diamant in
seiner Fassung also geschützt bleibt
habe ich kein Problem mit Frauensport
sie kann tun was sie möchte
Frauenrechte eines der Dinge über die
wir in unserem Land reden dürfen sagen
Ägypterinnen
der Staat schmückt sich mit neuen
Gesetzen zum Schutz der Frau aber die
Gesellschaft sei in ihrem Kern
frauenfeindlich
eine Frau kann Ministerin werden und
Verträge unterschreiben aber nicht der
Vormund ihrer Kinder sein
in einer meiner Zeichnungen ging es
darum dass Frauen als Straftäterinnen
genau wie Männer gesehen werden sie
bekommen die gleichen Strafen wie Männer
werden genauso hingerichtet bekommen
genauso lebenslänglich aber das
Zivilrecht betrachtet die Frau als Kind
nicht erwachsen unfähig ihr Leben und
das ihrer Kinder zu organisieren das ist
nicht logisch und muss sich ändern
ist preisgekrönte Karikaturistin jeden
Tag liefert sie eine Tageszeitung eine
Zeichnung jeden Tag kämpft sie mit der
Zensur
die Lage der Frau ist eines ihrer
wiederkehrenden Motive
nur mehr ich denke die Frauen sind immer
in einem Kampf ein Kampf um friedlich
auf der Straße laufen zu können in einem
Konflikt im Konflikt mit der
Gesellschaft im Konflikt mit den
Traditionen mit der Lage auf der Straße
selbst wenn Ihre Kleidung oder ihr Stil
etwas anders sind als gewöhnlich könnte
sie Probleme bekommen
die Frauen haben begonnen mehr zu reden
über Belästigung über Gewalt
aber die Hauptursache ist nicht behoben
wir reden nur über die Symptome der
Krankheit
sie schauen die afrikanische Champions
League
[Musik]
Kairos Spitzenklub räumt ab
verfolgen die Männer hier auch
Frauenfußball
izen gibt dann gucke ich das
in der arabischen Gesellschaft sehen wir
das nicht gern wir wurden nicht so
erzogen
sie werden nicht viele Leute finden die
Frauenfußball gucken da wäre dieses Café
nicht so voll wie jetzt die Spielerinnen
können kaum was Männer fußball ist in
Sachen Fitness Geschwindigkeit und
Strategie einfach besser
[Musik]
weiß als frauenfußballerin ist sie fast
unsichtbar in ihrem Land wie reagiert
sie auf die Hähne im Netz auf den Spott
der Trolle in den Medien ihr selbst in
der fußballföderation
[Musik]
ich ärgere mich sofort besonders wenn
ich fühle dass nicht nur ich
unterschätzt werde sondern auch der
Sport also das was ich liebe aber ich
sage mir am Ende des Tages ist das alles
nur Gerede
unsere Spielerinnen verdienen etwas
besseres ist Trainer
überzeugt er will mehr Turniere stärkere
Gegner als nur die ägyptische Liga der
Ehrgeiz sei bei vielen größer als die
Möglichkeiten
mit guter Planung würden jetzt zehn
Spielerinnen im Ausland spielen wir
brauchen mehr Unterstützung aus dem Land
selbst wir wünschten die
fußballföderation würde uns mehr als
bisher unterstützen
ein Zahnmedizinstudium und sechsmal
Fußballtraining in der Woche ihr Alltag
ist streng durchgeplant eigentlich
wollte Maja Sport oder Physiotherapie
studieren aber ihre Eltern drängten auf
Zahnmedizin
für Maja geht der Fußball vor für ihre
Mutter das Studium
mit Frauenfußball Comedy Tochter in
Ägypten nicht weit
zuerst dachte ich das Fußball nicht zu
einem Mädchen passt aber ihr Vater
spielte Fußball und sagte mir das
Mädchen sei begabt und dann sagte der
Onkel das auch alle sagten sie hat
Talent also willigte ich ein
bei den Spielen in Ägypten sind die
Eltern oft dabei
mit der neuen Generation sagen sie sei
es nicht ganz einfach sie sein stärker
hätten andere Ziele
hier wurden früher so erzogen dass alle
Anweisungen vom Vater von der Mutter von
der Familie kommen
aber jetzt entspringt alles dem eigenen
denken
[Musik]
was wäre wenn Ihre Tochter ein Angebot
bekäme im Ausland zu spielen
als die theoretisch ich wäre glücklicher
wenn sie Profi wäre in einem Land wo der
Frauenfußball besser ist als hier
porzaid am Mittelmeer
der Spielort der ägyptischen Hockey
Meisterschaften die Scharia traditionell
gewinnt
Maja safirdin und das Team haben die
Nacht am Meer verbracht
vor dem Finale dürfen wir den Frauen
keine ernsten Fragen mehr stellen bitte
der Trainer
naja ist nachdenklich wen kümmert es
schon wenn Sie hier wieder den Pokal
holen hatte sie sich im Gespräch mit mir
vor einigen Tagen gefragt
selbst wenn wir gewinnen gratulieren ein
oder zwei sonst niemand ich gebe dem
Sport mehr als ich zurück bekomme ich
fühle mich nicht zufrieden ich bin
erwachsen genug um mehr gesehen zu
werden als ich den Afrika Cup gewann
erfuhr niemand etwas über mich obwohl es
so unerwartet kam
die Ringe sind eher leer naja Dienst
Eltern sind nicht gekommen
Scharia macht früh einige Tore
[Applaus]
der Gegner bleibt chancenlos
was die männlichen Spieler im Publikum
wohl über die Frauen denken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie spielen nicht schlecht aber sie
brauchen Unterstützung damit sie das
Level erreichen dass wir uns in Ägypten
wünschen
sie brauchen finanzielle Hilfe
Sport die Ausrüstung muss importiert
werden
ihre Leistung ist gut sie sind nicht
schlecht anders als früher machen sie
Fortschritte
[Musik]
bleibt vorne und gewinnt 5 zu 0
wir waren richtig gut vorbereitet ich
bin happy weil die Mühen dieser Saison
sich ausgezahlt haben und wir das
verdienen
aber erst einmal müssen die Frauen
schnell das Feld verlassen und warten
bis die Männer gespielt haben
[Applaus]
drei Stunden später erst nach den
Freunden Sprüngen der Männer bekommen
die Frauen den Pokal und ihre Medaillen
zurück in Kairo
bei Ägyptens Nationalspielerinnen die
über Jahre keine Spiele absolvierten
jetzt aber wieder einen Platz haben auf
der FIFA Weltrangliste
Maja weiß in Ägypten zu bleiben macht
vieles schwerer als heiraten denkt die
18-Jährige noch lange nicht aber hier
einen Mann zu finden der ihre
Fußballleidenschaft teilt sei nicht ganz
einfach
ich habe mein eigenes Leben ohne
Rücksicht auf alles andere und ich habe
Dinge die ich erreichen muss ehrlich
gesagt mein Ziel ist es aus Ägypten
rauszukommen das wäre ein guter Schritt
in meinem Alter in einem Land wie
England zu spielen oder dort weiter zu
studieren das würde mir in allem helfen
ich wäre eine gute Repräsentantin meines
Landes sagt Maja das käme dem
Nationalteam zugute
eines Tages ist sie sich sicher werden
dir Ägypterinnen an der WM teilnehmen